she
is a global superstar he is probably the
world's
loneliest elephant for the best part of
20 years
gavin has been living in islamabad zoo
mistreated
chained and all alone the 35 year old
overweight
bull elephant is now being rescued by a
powerful
international advocate
it was in 2016 when cher first learned
of garvin's plight
with her wildlife protection charity she
hired a legal team
to press for the elephant's freedom in
may this year
the high court in pakistan ruled that
govern should be set free
the oscar-winning actress called it one
of the greatest moments of her life
it's more than clear that you can't keep
elephants
alone and not in such an environment and
of course this is a huge animal welfare
issue
gavin is now on his way to his new home
in cambodia
where plenty of other elephants are
waiting for him in their 1 million acre
wildlife sanctuary
but doctors say even there he will
require years
of physical and psychological assistance
i have the feeling kavan is waiting to
go to his new home
where he will be an elephant he will be
retired and you will have
three ladies a theater elephant are
waiting for him there
govan only ended up in pakistan after
the former military ruler
general zeal huck persuaded sri lanka to
make a present of the elephant to his
daughter
for years gavin has entertained crowds
from just a small
barren patch of land treated poorly and
forgotten by many
[Music]
but not anymore from now on his desolate
enclosure
will only be a bad memory as the big old
bull
embarks on a new life in a new land
[Music]
in rashid sky news